eu gostaria de falar pra vocês hoje quer
dizer o tema destaque é a ufrj que
queremos para os nossos filhos meu caso
para os nossos netos né
mas a ufrj que nós queremos pra pensar
lá é necessário que eu conte pra vocês
um pouco da minha trajetória acadêmica e
da minha trajetória pessoal eu entrei na
universidade da ufmg pra faculdade de
direito quando eu tinha 16 anos de idade
o que por si só já é um problema a gente
entrar para a universidade tem que
construir uma carreira acadêmica é
quando a gente ainda não consegue lidar
com os próprios hormônios né
então eu entrei para a universidade não
sabia o que estava fazendo ali eu não
sabia o que era o curso de direito eu
não sabia eu só não sabia então é entrar
para a universidade pra mim foi uma
violência foi como me tirar do meu mundo
e transportar para um universo
totalmente desconhecido é pra completar
essa história eu fui mãe aos 18 anos de
idade e teve dois filhos seguidos então
aos 19 anos eu era mãe de duas crianças
estudantes da universidade na graduação
de um curso que não sabia para que
servia
ou seja a minha graduação foi um horror
é eu não conseguia me entrosar com a
minha turma eu não conseguia é lidar com
a minha vida cuidar da minha casa eu não
conseguia fazer nada direito
a universidade portanto pra mim não
existiu durante o período da graduação
quando eu terminei a graduação eu não
tinha criado vínculos com a minha turma
por ter portanto é tentar na construção
de uma carreira cadeia de uma carreira
jurídica né
nas possibilidades que seriam oferecidas
depois de formada e isto simplesmente
não existiu
eu saí da faculdade eu era uma boa aluna
apesar dos pesares tim bom histórico
escolar
tinha uma formação técnica mas eu não
sabia o que estava fazendo ali por
aquele curso de direito àquele diploma
nas mãos
então o que eu fiz eu fui é pensar em me
colocar no mercado de trabalho
e essa questão foi pra mim é horrível
foi horrível na época que eu me formei e
me formei em 1986 não havia concursos
públicos na área de direito como há hoje
é você tinha e uma outra possibilidade
de fazer carreira como juízo como
promotor de justiça mas não era essa
febre de concurso que passou a existir
depois dos anos 90 no brasil
então a minha perspectiva como a maior
parte dos meus colegas era simplesmente
entrar para a carreira da advocacia
privada me colocar em algum escritório e
aí eu comecei a me deparar com o
primeiro grande o segundo grande é que é
o primeiro grande problema da minha vida
acadêmica e profissional que era questão
de gênero ela já tinha aparecido lá
atrás quando eu tinha duas crianças e
tinha que estudar e tinha que cuidar dos
meus filhos e não tinha com quem dividir
essa tarefa já existia
ela já me acompanhava foi minimizada na
na graduação porque ufmg tinha creche
tinha creche para alunas para
funcionárias e para é é professoras
então como tinha creche para os nossos
com os meus filhos eu consegui concluir
a graduação mas quando eu tento me
colocar no mercado do trabalho
com 21 anos de idade propriedade com a
qual não formei eu era jovem eu era
bonita
naquela época eu era bonita então era
uma tragédia isso só pesava contra mim
eu chegava nos escritórios fazer a
entrevista tinha um bom histórico mas eu
era uma mulher jovem e bonita no
pensamento e pior
divorciada tinha acabado de me separar
do marido meu ex-marido a no dicionário
sexista essa trilogia jovem bonita e
bronzeada significa disponível né
então eu não queria estar disponível eu
não estava disponível e portanto eu não
conseguir emprego eu já estava começando
a pensar em é fazer brigadeiro para
vender para fora quando um belo dia um
encontro com este professor de graduação
professor muito querido e ele falou como
é que está fazendo e pensando em vender
brigadeiro
ele disse 'não vanessa você tem que
voltar para o seu lugar que é a
universidade e eu fiquei assim sem saber
se eu realmente iria voltar voltei
voltei a pós-graduação para mim passou a
ser a porta de entrada para a
universidade na minha mesa na minha
história de vida a graduação ela não
existiu
a pós graduação foi a porta de entrada
para o conhecimento foi a porta de
entrada para o universo acadêmico
universo completamente desconhecido para
mim até aquele momento dentro da
pós-graduação eu comecei a descobrir que
eu não precisava estudar só
procedimentos na área do direito
eu descobri que eu podia estudar
sociologia que eu podia estudar a
história que eu podia estudar artes e
isso pra mim foi uma coisa inacreditável
eu decidi então a partir dali que eu
seguir uma carreira acadêmica foi na pós
graduação que eu fiz
efetivamente amigos na universidade
tanto que hoje a maior parte dos meus
amigos na área do direito são
professores de direito não são juízes
não só é advogado não só promotores
embora também existam tá gente mas na
minha vida os amigos mesmo que ficar me
acompanha até hoje foram aqueles que
fizeram comigo curso de pós graduação é
terminada a minha o meu primeiro ciclo
na pós-graduação mestrado
eu ingressei no doutorado imediatamente
e naquela época havia concursos públicos
para professor assistente ou seja na
época o professor assistente é aquele
que tinha o título de mestrado abrir um
concurso em filosofia do direito e
introdução ao estudo do direito da ufmg
eu fiz o concurso foi aprovada ou seja
aos 24 anos de idade de 25 anos eu era
professora da universidade federal de
minas gerais na faculdade de direito
quando entrei na faculdade de direito
como professora é ocorreu um fenômeno
comum nas faculdades de direito
as disciplinas a a disciplinas das
faculdades de direito que são lecionadas
em outros cursos
de engenharia no curso de economia no
curso de administração
ora eu era uma jovem professora eu
estava cursando doutorado eu só era
mestre ou seja eu era a mais baixa
escala na hierarquia acadêmica dentro da
faculdade direito o que eles fizeram
comigo me colocaram para dar aula fora
da faculdade de direito
então eu saí da faculdade direito para
dar aula para os futuros engenheiros
economistas e contadores certo então
isto era uma espécie de de estágio
probatório uma espécie de geladeira eles
me colocaram nessa geladeira
isso pra mim foi a melhor coisa que me
aconteceu na vida no momento em que eu
entrei na escola de engenharia para a
faculdade de ciências econômicas e
administração
eu pude conviver é viver uma experiência
que a maior parte dos professores que
são vamos dizer assim monogâmicos né
sua única disciplina não consegue viver
eu tinha que preparar aulas que fossem
adequadas
aquilo que esperava um futuro economista
da área do direito
o futuro engenheiro da área do direito e
dentro das engenharias
eu precisava também fazer malabarismos
porque o que quer saber onde é um
engenheiro de minas não é exatamente o
que o engenheiro civil precisa saber
sobre o direito
então além de aprender mais sobre a
minha própria em minha própria formação
eu tive a oportunidade de conviver com
outras áreas e aprender outras coisas né
entretanto a minha pesquisa no doutorado
é concomitante à essa experiência
acadêmica ela foi sendo paulatinamente
direcionada pra discussão dos direitos
humanos
alguém aqui conhece alguma coisa que
seja mais interdisciplinar do que os
direitos humanos alguma coisa que possa
romper as barreiras do conhecimento do
que os direitos humanos
então eu comecei a trabalhar direitos
humanos e essa pesquisa acabou levando a
uma conclusão de uma tese de doutorado
que era uma área
muito diferente da área do meu
departamento
naquela época tá então a o estudo de
direitos humanos ele estava concentrado
nas faculdades de direito nos
departamentos de direito constitucional
e direito internacional público
ou seja eu passei a ser uma professora
fora de contexto
dentro do departamento para o qual eu
tive eu tinha feito concurso
qual foi a solução apresentada eu fiz
outro concurso na porta ao lado
então eu fiz um concurso mudei de porta
essa mudança de de sala dentro da no
mesmo andar na faculdade de direito da
ufmg teve uma consequência que foi a
seguinte eu ali dentro da da daquele
departamento
a expectativa é que eu fosse uma
professora de direito constitucional
direito constitucional capes locke só eu
trabalhava com direitos humanos por
trabalhar com direitos humanos
a minha trajetória natural era eu tinha
desvios ou seja é eu não conseguia falar
de direitos humanos ó nóis na esfera do
direito constitucional
eu precisava trabalhar com o direito
internacional eu tinha
sentia falta de estudar ciência política
eu tinha que entender alguma coisa de
economia eu tinha que saber relações
internacionais
então eu fiquei absolutamente aborrecida
naquele departamento dando aula de
direito constitucional só para o curso
de direito foi tão chocante para mim
essa experiência foi tão avassaladora
que eu decidi fazer outro curso de
graduação
terminei o doutorado e fui fazer
arquitetura
aí comecei a fazer arquitetura e por
vários motivos naquela naquela época eu
não conseguir não terminei o curso fiz o
curso até quase o final quando estava
chegando perto do final o abandonei o
curso e fui fazer uma especialização em
história da arte da arquitetura
seja a minha grande insatisfação era a
faculdade de direito eu não me cabe a
mim eu não cabia naquele espaço
eu não cabia naquele espaço porque ele
era um espaço que não era
interdisciplinar porque ele era um
espaço no qual eu não me sentia incluída
então eu ficava nesse drama neste língua
sem saber exatamente o que eu estava
fazendo ali as pessoas olhavam pra mim
não sabe exatamente o que eu estava
fazendo ali também e eu fiquei dando
aula dando aula e plural por vários
motivos
acabei me demitindo da ufmg me demite da
ufmg e vim para a ufrj há dez anos que
estou na ufrj eu tenho 25 anos de
carreira acadêmica
então quando eu vim para o sr j eu
cheguei numa faculdade de direito da
faculdade nacional de direito que era
terra arrasada
a faculdade nacional de direito ela
tinha sido completamente desmontada
durante a ditadura militar por ter sido
desmontada durante a ditadura militar
ela era uma universidade é uma faculdade
que não tinha estrutura física precisa
ter uma idéia a gente utilizar o
banheiro do bar do manoel que era em
frente no largo do caco não tinha
banheiro funcionando na faculdade
nacional
ela tinha acabado de sofrer uma
intervenção do conselho universitário
então eu entrei nessa nova leva de
professoras foi uma coisa magnífica
porque a partir dali eu e os novos
colegas recém ingresso na faculdade
nacional de direito tinha que tínhamos
que reconstruir a graduação a pós
graduação ea própria estrutura física do
prédio da faculdade nacional de direito
era um projeto coletivo e eu me sentia
extremamente acolhida por esse projeto
dentro da ufrj então é a a naquele
momento nós
arregaçamos as mangas e fomos
reconstruir o currículo acadêmico
trazendo pra dentro aquilo que nós
professores que tínhamos acabado de
ingressar pensávamos que fosse
importante
trouxemos outros elementos que não
aqueles aquele núcleo duro do direito
que estava presente na minha faculdade
de direito da ufmg uma faculdade
tradicional antiga
não tinha sofrido essa ruptura nós
começamos vimos a possibilidade de
trazer sociologia antropologia ciência
política história pra dentro do nosso
programa e nós fizemos isto e criamos
uma pós graduação que tem uma linha de
pesquisa uma linha de mania de
concentração absolutamente inédita e se
chama direitos humanos sociedade arte e
aí eu me encaixei aí eu encontrei o meu
lugar
então é a universidade ela a algumas
questões para responder à pergunta qual
a universidade que nós queremos que é eu
considero extremamente relevantes
a primeira primeira questão a
universidade ela tem que ser inclusiva
ela tem que ser inclusiva desde a
graduação e este ser inclusivo significa
nós temos que desenvolver afectos
nós professores precisamos de ser um
pouco do nosso tablado
nós precisamos aprender com os nossos
alunos como eu fui uma jovem professora
eu não me sentia incluída porque eu
estava lá embaixo na estrutura da
academia como estudante eu não me sentia
acolhida de forma alguma na graduação
então a universidade que eu quero para
os meus filhos para os meus netos essa
ufrj ela tem que ser inclusive ela tem
que trazer para dentro as mulheres
há vários mecanismos possíveis né
o jovem como eu naquela época com filhos
pequenos se eu não tivesse creche eu não
teria me informado não estaria aqui
conversando com vocês
essa universidade ela tem que ser
incluída para as classes sociais que
sempre foram alijados desses processos
elas precisam estar aqui dentro não é só
a questão das cotas é necessário que nós
pensemos na forma de efetivamente fazer
com essa universidade seja participativa
nas tomadas de decisão
nós temos que ser inclusivos em relação
à a arritmia a raça todas essas questões
têm que estar presentes nas nossas
discussões nas nossas funções como
professores não só de direitos
anos com professores na área de artes
como professores da área de ciência e
tecnologia como professor de medicina
elas têm que estar presentes estão a
universidade que eu quero uma
universidade que seja inclusive a
segunda questão em relação à
universidade a partir dessa minha
trajetória acadêmica e pessoal
essa universidade ela tem que criar
formas de conciliar o saber da graduação
com saber da pós graduação
não é razoável que nós formamos na
graduação meros técnicos que a gente não
traga uma reflexão mais profunda para os
nossos cursos de graduação esta foi a
minha experiência e não foi boa né
então é necessário que a gente crie
essas pontes de conciliação entre
graduação e pós graduação não pagava em
um degrau entre elas a segunda a
terceira questão de me comove e quando
eu penso a ufrj que nós queremos
e pra mim é uma das mais importantes é a
ideia de ter finalidade
nós precisamos conversar entre nós nós
precisamos fazer conexões entre os
diversos saberes nós precisamos romper
as hierarquias de saberes dentro da
universidade hierarquia de poder
hierarquia de saber se nós não fizermos
isto nós não conseguiremos refundar a
universidade e refundar a universidade
no meu entendimento é fazer com que ela
efetivamente seja o que diz o vocábulo
latino universo das né totalidade um
pouco de tudo um pouco
obrigado